no dude i have i have certain things
that i've never said
that i will only say for the first time
i'm sorry bro on rogan wow really i've
been making a list wait have you not
gone on rogan no but you guys are
familiar with each other you're friends
man for sure you're not friends no i
won't even say we're acquaintances
friendly friendly with each other yeah
yeah i think it's so when does this
happen he had high praise for you after
the mayweather fight he's always he's
always been so i'm big i think he's
[ __ ] awesome he's always been so kind
to us even when the world wasn't he's
the man he's yeah dude that's dude every
time i met him he's he's awesome um yeah
why why haven't we made that happen i
think you guys but no no it's it's it's
no rush i'm gonna get i'll give him a
[ __ ] good ass reason to have me on
proper one day you know if he if he
doesn't feel it's right yeah it's not
you know no rush i'll be around
i've got some i got some big things
coming i think you need i think i yeah
man get up on there i need i need some i
need some i'm kind of
i need i need a i need a big a big
reason i need something i need something
you know i'm saying i'm i'm lulling
right now a fight i'm stagnant
big fight yeah big fight
i'm saying like whatever it is it needs
to be like
i don't know do you feel that
yeah for sure dude part of my part of my
business is underst is gauging the
culture's
feeling about my
brand yeah
it's funny i'm referring to like
myself as a brand but like dude you know
real life logan isn't always the same as
online logo
i i i try to make it you know pretty
close but yeah you know definitely like
sometimes you're a bit performative
you know i'm [ __ ] chilling in your
life i don't i'm just hanging out
but online it's it's good to it's good
to amplify certain parts of your
personnel and you could feel if it was
you could feel like a period that's a
lull yeah for sure does anyone give a
[ __ ] about your [ __ ]
it's hard it's hard to keep people
interested but are you still putting out
things
yeah yeah like 99 originals prime et
cetera but like in terms of you having a
big fight a big moment a big specific
thing for sure i think i think so like
so like
prime's pretty pretty mass prime's
pretty originals is a bit more niche you
have to like appreciate like art
and like then like stories like that and
most importantly nfcs and crypto most
people [ __ ] don't give a [ __ ] they
already they chalk it up whatever fine
but
the rest of the stuff i put out like how
how how adoptable is it by the masses
wwe i find it for like anyone can watch
and be entertaining yeah same with
boxing again the playground analogy like
everyone goes to the [ __ ] fight at
the playground like same with real life
everyone likes it original some of the
other [ __ ] i do is maybe might be a
little more niche might might not appeal
to everyone i'm like i'm like
i'm quirky
like i like weird [ __ ] bro like i
[ __ ] collect pokemon cards how do you
make people care about that yeah how do
you make people give a [ __ ] about
pokemon cards yeah how did you because i
give a [ __ ]
and i'm good at connecting those dots
when i care about something
i feel like i have
gotten semi-good
at telling a story in a way that makes
other people care as well it intrigues
them enough to invest themselves and
they'll connect with me emotionally like
half this i just want to make people
feel good or bad i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah have a sensation yeah bro if people
are indifferent to you
the worst that's the worst fascinating
story about you is from uh your editor
hayden oh no he said a story just on his
on his youtube but he was saying that
they'd never looked you correct me if
i'm wrong never looked at any youtube
analytics for like years like when your
channel is popping off and it was never
analytics or never like ever you just
felt what the people needed hayden
chalked it up to just you being like
just penetrating through the screen i i
won't i won't look at analytics i mean
that's not true i will but it's not like
it's not my determinant does that make
sense right my taste is my determinant
for what i make and what i release and
what i would press uh publish on yeah um
what do you mean your taste
like i my my opinion on what a good
story is is the the reason why i press
publish or do not press publish it's not
because uh i think a video will get good
views i don't give a [ __ ]
my engagement's even gone down after
originals again it's like you're
flooding your your page with a certain
type of content only resonates with a
certain type of person like the
algorithm's gonna put you in a spot and
then you go fighting and it'll go back
up it's just it's it's it's it's waves
it's crest and troughs like it's it's a
natural form of like any endeavor
especially when you've been doing it as
long as i have right do this [ __ ] for so
[ __ ] long andrew yeah i've been doing
this [ __ ] forever
and like i've refined
a storytelling taste that
resonates with
some people sometimes so that's what you
look at the videos as stories my resume
yeah am i happy to have this on my
resume do i think this is a do i think
this is
important do i think it could entertain
which is where i start i wanted to be
the biggest entertainer in the world do
i think it could add value
do i think it could distract a lot of
people have [ __ ] lives
like they need a little distraction how
many why are people watching this right
now
yeah for a distraction